hi everyone it's jerry let's have a look
at a game from round five of the 44th
chess olympiad
this was team zambia vs team norway
on the white end international master
gyllenbullia
and he's paired against magnus carlson
okay
we have on board
a queen's gambit declined bishop b4
denotes the regoza and this is a 26
mover
the game has
a nice logical flow to it carlson
executes a simple
light square strategy
he does have a knack for making some of
his games look
simple and
this is one of them
all right from here is e3 castles
bishop's questioned
seven moves in
a couple notes
minor piece and bounce
white with the bishop pair white with an
unopposed dark square bishop
and after this last recapture on c3
there are weaknesses to speak of c3 and
c4 are holes
however of the two it's really c4 that
should stick out more than
well of the two with c4 that should
stick out
because black has a pawn they're
controlling that square already
the fourth rank squares are in general
going to be the more accessible squares
to the black pieces
and it is not already
too early a stage to be thinking as
black hey how can i maneuver one of my
pieces to get into that weak square
all right
first things first flank pawns like to
attack center pawns queen has a
an open lane note the timing of this
capture on c4
when exactly does that happen
okay bishop d3 is now the time
it is
black is only capturing on c4
after the light square bishop has taken
a step
this guy had to work extra hard had to
take a second step
to recapture on c4
so a little bit of patience by black
forced white to lose a move
okay
we have black now x-raying
the unprotected bishop
this is a threat
white does need to react to this last
move
in the game
knight d2 is played defending the bishop
if white
carried on with development castling
here and said
i'm prepared to meet pawn takes pawn
with queen takes pawn that's not good
and the reason for that is because this
c3 pawn is going to be screaming how
could you do this to me
why'd you leave me hanging it doesn't
want to be isolated
in short this
c takes d
white always wants to be in a spot to
meet c takes d with c takes d and as a
result
the pawns stay together a nice pawn
island of five
okay white's idea with knight d2 the
primary function behind this is to
defend the bishop
a few moves down the road we'll see what
that secondary idea is
it's not a losing idea but it is not
it's also not optimal
what is considered best instead of
knight to d2 is bishop to e2
and i'd like to put on a few moves here
just so we can get a feel for how play
can develop what is
maybe
a primary idea behind bishop to e2 okay
let me put on a few moves let's say
both
bishops are fee and keto'd and this rook
gets to a half open file
why does the bishop get out of the get
off of the c4 square it's so that this
guy
could get to c4
is so that the pawn
is no longer in
the unopposed dark square bishop's way
white is only a move away of maybe a
push or a capture at some stage and the
bishop is free to see the other side of
the board
this is one way to activate the dark
square bishop and it is the dark square
bishop
in this game that turns out to be a real
struggling piece
alright in this game it is knight to d2
knight to c6
there is no fear there shouldn't be any
fear by black oh i can't recapture on c5
if this there's that this guy will fall
shortly
and this guy again is not going to be
too happy
okay no bite on c5 instead castles
and from here black could play e5
additional pressure on d4
is the idea but if you play e5 right now
there's d5 it's a different structure
it's not
you know
significantly better for either side
but
carlson's idea is to preface the e5 move
play rook d8 first get to this half open
file
and next up he's looking for that one
right if if white plays a flight square
move now e5 could be played and there's
no d5
all right
what is white's secondary idea behind
knight to d2
f4
this pawn is now free
so
with every pawn move there is a positive
and negative to speak of
so what is the positive
it's stopping e5
the negative
there is a big weakness now on e4
there's a weakness on
c4 i already noted and now
this weakness on e4 is one that
could maybe be taken advantage of
um
this light square strategy
i'm referring to can maybe be summarized
in
three steps
step one is to first and foremost
recognize a weakness
so in our case here
let's focus on
the e4 square it's a hole it's a center
square a fourth rank square
step two is probably the most
uh
sophisticated
of the three
not not so easily executed in in many
cases but
it's maybe
described like this step two is
create conditions
that
make it possible for the weakened square
to be
accessible
to your pieces
the final step step three is to simply
move your piece
to the weak and square
that's the fun part
it's really step two creating these
conditions that make it
so that you could
gain access to that weak point
okay let's see what black's approach
he kicks off with knight to d5
this isn't considered best
computer's pointing out knight to a5
first
okay he runs with
knight to d5 and this does target
two weaknesses c3 and e3
and white's reply is to
capture the knight
not best
uh considered best is knight to e4 in
this position or
queen to e1 even
this could definitely turn out to be
very messy knight to e4 does defend c3
and e3
again it does get a little bit messy
another line this queenie one computer
says
be okay with giving up the pawn i guess
this dark square bishop will
uh find some activity on the main
diagonal
okay not a path uh
you know the white didn't go for this he
ended up capturing
the knight on d5
pop quiz first one of this video how
would you recapture on d5
feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
in the game it is pawn takes
now i think for many a train of thought
maybe
well i went to this half open file i
want to keep my rook on a half open file
and i also want to watch over this pawn
however it is best to take with the pawn
and let's see exactly
why
just pointing out
this square is a weakness it's nice to
have a pawn controlling this hole well
now it's
doing wonders it's watching over both e4
and c4
as well as creating a condition creating
a path into
the f5 square
this guy right here
right
in this position we would really like to
get to e4 we'd like to put all our
pieces there but this guy cannot simply
teleport to e4 we need to create paths
right so after this capture recapture we
can now see a path into e4
all right
additionally one one final one final
point is that remember the positive i
noted behind f4 what was it doing
when it went to f4 it was stopping
the e5 pawn break
well in a way
isn't black now saying you know what
when i convert my e-pawn into a d-pawn
now what are you even defending against
i don't have an e-pawn anymore
and
this pawn is now backward and accessible
to major pieces
so my point here
is that what was once at least
a small positive for white in playing f4
restricting an e5 pawn break
it serves now no purpose whatsoever
and it's really only seen at this stage
as a glaring weakness
okay
from here play continues with queen h5
carlson captures on d4
white recaptures
i had questioned
why exactly
capture
right now
i believe
a train of thought may be
as black you know what i want to ensure
that
a white pawn is fixed
on this dark square
and
once i'm assured that a pawn is fixed on
this dark square i won't have to worry
about the bishop for example ever
you know functioning well on the main
diagonal
where is that dark square bishop going
to function
in the game it ends up on the a3 to f8
diagonal not the
most brilliant diagonal in the world but
it does uh
it does serve some purpose eventually
but
you know if if black is not capturing on
d4 here let's uh let's say
some night move is made
and then you know there could be this
idea where the pawn moves
and then or i should say there could be
some general idea where there's this
capture
and then this pawn could move clearing
the way in this specific case of course
it's seriously
faulty there's queen takes e3 check but
the general pawn advances there is a way
now for white to clear a path
for the dark square bishop on the main
diagonal
okay with this specific capture right
now
black ensures that there will be no
activity for the dark square bishop on
the main diagonal
only at this point only after that
capture on d4 does black now
maneuver this is
um
this is step two in action right here
the the capture on d5 is
is one of the conditions black is
creating a condition to weave his way
into e4
knight to e7 is paving the way for
bishop to f5
okay
knight to f3
i had questioned what if white is
interfering with if this is a good idea
for black why isn't
white interfering with bishop to f5
um this would not be a good move for why
f5
can you see why throw it to you as a pop
quiz black to play what would you play
here
okay here we go
you could capture on f5 with the bishop
or knight
i'll show just one of them
bishop takes pawn
rook takes and now we have this
follow-up g6
now at first glance i thought oh okay
this is the end of it you're going to
get the material back but not so fast it
it does run a little bit deeper
there is a way to save
these two pieces
with rook g5 the pawn is pinned there's
no pawn takes queen
out of the knights reach
but while these guys are now hanging out
over here biting on a rock g6 this queen
could now be in
a super pest
poke around at these weak points the
rook
take a pawn with check you can't go to
the corner you're going to get mated in
two
and if you go here there's going to be
the old rover rook up and over
and this is going to be this is going to
be very painful for white there's no
good defense
if the queen comes back well the rook
would fall
if the knight moves there's this check
and the rook is going to fall
and if black if white wants to be in a
position to meet this check
with the night block and wants to put
the rook on a safer looking square
that's still not going to work because
after this check
this queen is going to find a way to
track down the rook one way or the other
king here that's one way to pick off the
rook
king here you could take the pawn the
knight is pinned
getting the rook next
and finally
if the king goes here you flick in this
check first force the king
into a spot where the knight is pinned
and then
take on d4 once more you'll track down
the rook
okay in short f5 is tactically flawed
knight f3 played bishop f5
bishop d2
a
restricting move
no no great forward knight moves
from here knight h4
bishop e4
mission accomplished just like that
how are you going to challenge this guy
a real beast
now i only referenced
um
three
steps
you know this this simple strategy
three steps
to achieve these three steps have
achieved a superior post for one of your
pieces now if you want to take it a step
further
we transition
towards
no longer strategy but it's more
more so uh dynamics
tactics step four would be well
with that now uh superior bishop on e4
how can i connect with it
look at the squares it's observing it's
pointing right at the heart
of white's king side
it would really be nice if a rook could
get to the second rank
this doesn't happen
in the game
um you know the coordination on g2 but
it's a nice train of thought to have how
can i coordinate really well with that
monster bishop on e4
okay
from here we have f5
here's one other one other note
this bishop is very good on e4
um but
maybe even better in some positions it
could be the knight
let me let me highlight a scenario where
that may come about let's say queen
g4 is played
and
black could go
with some maneuver step two in action
uh repositioning the knight knight c8
into d6 let's say the knight jumps here
you can knock out the knight make a cool
move like queen f7
if you try
knight d6 right now this would fall
but one simple move
queen f7 this is hitting next
it really can't be stopped with bishop
here this guy will be scared away
from this diagonal
so the queen maybe backs off and then i
think at this stage
playing as black your most difficult
decision will be
deciding which of these two amazing
squares should i go to with the knight
okay
another way we could see
uh
black
uh work with this light square strategy
the bishop stands well but so too does a
knight more often than not it's the
knight that is amazing on e4
all right in this game it's f5
rook to c8
bishop to b4
a5 bishop takes knight queen takes
and now we have this rook up and over
idea but these guys are going to turn
out to be
misplaced
i was pointing out getting to the second
rank i guess as it is right now there's
this is going to be secure enough
the knight is watching over the rook i
watch over
what is black doing he's putting
pressure on the weak points
e3
and a three
one of them is going to fall
white defends e3
queen takes a3
and rook to g4
uh it may seem a little scary
you got these two majors
but uh
the timing is not right there's
they're they're not really coordinating
well enough on any one specific square
to cause any problems to black
and you know when you have when you have
a player go in
kind of this is kind of an all-in
approach
when these
you have these rook lifts
a nice tactical approach
um you know when you're the defending
side is to recognize you know what
there's now a lone defender on your back
rank
if i could get rid of this guy
your king is really gonna feel some
uh he's gonna experience some problems
so this is what we have
black looks to get rid of this main
defender
and there really isn't a good solution
for white here he ends up capturing on
c1 and that runs into uh
maintain two
now with queen takes rook
queen takes e3
and there's only two choices you go to
the corner queen takes rook
or the move played in the game this one
did go straight to mate
and it is
this light square bishop that
finishes the game off
bishop d3
and that's game over
anyhow a nice uh i believe at least uh
instructive game here 26 mover
a simple light square
strategy
in action
anyhow as usual
feel free
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comments section below
i hope you enjoyed it
and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you